vanessa thanks for that meantime on to
our coronavirus coverage where the
shelves are empty the lines are long so
many of you are on the hunt for one of
those at-home covet tests this video
over my shoulder shows long lines from
the testing center and the unlv campus
last night for a check on things tonight
let's head right out to victoria saha
victoria
victoria
hey brian and denise this testing site
is set to open in about a half an hour
we spoke to people all the way in the
front who've been waiting for three
hours just so they became they can be
guaranteed a test but take a look behind
me the line just keeps growing
the lines every day this week stretched
onto the city's streets by unlv everyone
wanting to get their hands on a coveted
19 test when we were here last monday
after christmas there were 300 tests
being given out and last night there
were more than 1700 tests we spoke to
tania landrum she got in line two hours
before this site opened yesterday and
had to wait for four hours only to be
turned away i probably got
around to the parking lot around 8 30
and by the time i reached the game they
told me that they had reached maximum
capacity i was a little disappointed i
thought two hours would be enough but
it wasn't she got in line today three
hours ahead but there were still
multiple cars ahead of her
now this site offers vaccines but they
do not have pediatric doses the site is
open sunday through thursday 5 30 to 10
30 p.m reporting from the unlv campus
tonight victoria saha live local now